if you're a fiscal conservative and i've  heard you say that you are you should  favor the cheaper how do we have this  guy for those procedures and not paying  for what it would cost to find and  discharge all those transgender  members david you're not here to  communicate i really appreciate you  coming on i'm going to let you go it's a  waste of time to talk to you we're not  communicating you're actually like  because you're asking bizarre questions  you're acting like an idiot and you're  wasting my time i appreciate that  all right thanks for coming goodbye  goodbye  let him go  that's a progressive folks  all men who are progressive or males who  are progressive are we people  they are weak people and why have these  people on it doesn't even make sense  they don't come to communicate  because they're too insecure and david  pac-man is a very insecure  progressive  real men are not progressive